[Music]
do you mean just gonna say it I gotta
let you go
you were just fired oz let go for
liability reasons involving insurance
the one-armed bartender know your solo
spec Charlotte Motor Speedway I know how
they move the money
the only God knows anything about
blowing up real bank vaults is Joe banks
I am in car sir ring and yeah we got a
plan to get you the coca-cola 600 is the
biggest race of the year we need a
computer with us I know everything there
is to know about computers okay all the
Twitter's I know
welcome to the coca-cola 600 how many
boards Hawaii's evolved 20 yards
I don't read 30 is it 20 or is it 30 we
are dealing with science here they're
gonna know what we want them to know my
life of crime is over
[Music]
is massively stupid it's gonna handle oh
this is gonna be good that looks like it
hurt
[Music]
I want everything on Jimmy Logan I'm
about get naked so no bacon
I said no bacon you moment must be a
simple nod in his people sign maybe
we'll say that what you get in my arm
please
is it this one
[Music]